as always aldana needs to stop shooting
missile launchers in movies because she
is way too skinny to make that
believable
Columbiana is a film that is produced by
Luke based on as we all know he loves
movies that are either revenge related
young girls being assassins or assassins
in general or something like that now
yes a lot of the symbols are very
cliched but a nicer way to say that is
Luke based on likes movies where there
is a strong female character that's a
different way of looking at him isn't it
so Columbiana star zoe saldana and from
a young age she grew up her parents were
killed right in front of her and she's
basically vowed revenge against all
people involved with that so basically
the film is how she goes from hit to hit
to get to the people who were involved
with the death of her parents when she
was a little girl the director of this
film is a directed directed transporter
3 a transporter 3 is not good I had fun
with transporter 1 and 2 honestly the
third one was pretty bad because how can
you direct a movie with Jason Statham
and make the fight scenes look bad you
use cheesy CGI sped up slow motion kicks
and punches the Jason Statham can do
perfectly fine all on his own
don't do that crap guess what he doesn't
get in Columbiana
we'll get back to that later Zoe Saldana
is good in this film I really liked her
character and I thought that she added a
really nice believability to some
incredibly unbelievable stuff I actually
enjoyed the first half of this movie I
thought that it was handled pretty well
I liked her character I liked how they
showed her sneaking and being stealth
full and I like if she approached her
targets
I liked her relationship with her
adoptive father I thought he did a good
job I liked the first half of this movie
I thought it was handled well Michael
Vartan who I don't know if he's been in
a movie for like ten years or something
he's been in a few random things it
seems like he's signed on to this movie
because it gets to make I was always a
laconic because he really doesn't have
much to do there's 22 wounded the new
Lance
for years I'm doing this my way she's
going after us she's just a girl take
care of it but basically towards the
last half of the film everything has got
really mashed up action didn't seem good
anymore the choreography was really
really poorly done and it also features
one of the worst fight scenes I have
seen all year in regards to how it was
filmed how realistic it looked I mean it
was just awful choreography and unfair
opponents hidden by terrible editing Zoe
Saldana is beautiful she's very sexy in
this movie however she is essentially a
very skinny little girl and she faces
off against this big guy dandy is really
crappy editing and effects to make it
look like she was actually winning it
was seriously one of the worst fight
scenes I've seen this year
basically the entire last time for this
movie just fell apart character
motivations seem strange things didn't
make sense it got completely
unbelievable and I just felt bad because
the first half of the film was like a
fun revenge spy kind of thriller and
then it just fell apart into something
that was completely different and it
just really got to be for me because of
the fact that I like the first half I'm
gonna give the film a C+ I will not stop
you feel what I felt all these years
yeah I don't hate myself for watching
the movie or anything I wasn't saying
they're like oh and or anything it's
just that I I'd really fell apart in the
last half for me so unfortunately I'm
not gonna recommend seeing Columbiana
but if you liked my review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stopping
eyes